[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Looking to
build a flexible, smart,
and secure data
analytics platform?
Give me one minute, and I'll
show you how Dataplex can help.
Enterprises have
distributed data
across data lakes, data
warehouses, and data marts.
They service a
diverse set of users
who want data available across
various tools for analytics
and machine learning.
This is extremely
difficult to manage,
as IT needs to build and manage
the connections between all
these analytics tools,
replicate security, governance,
and metadata management,
and balance multiple pricing
models.
Dataplex is an intelligent
data fabric that can help.
It unifies your distributed
data to help automate data
management and power
your analytics at scale
with an integrated
analytics experience.
What does this mean to you?
It enables standardization
and unification
of metadata, security
policies, governance, and data
classification for
consistent controls
across storage devices.
Data intelligence using
Google's best in class
AI ML capabilities is built
in to automate data discovery,
metadata harvesting, lifecycle
management, and data quality.
This automatically
makes data securely
accessible for
analytics and data
science via a variety of Google
Cloud native and open source
tools and Dataplex's integrated
analytics experience,
no matter where the data lives.
Dataplex offers you a
single pane of glass
to organize, curate,
secure, and analyze
your data while giving
you the flexibility
to store data where you see
fit and use the best analytics
tools for the job.
With Dataplex, you no longer
have to build or manage
the fabric that holds your data
analytics platform together.
We have you covered.
So next time you're looking
to take your analytics
to plan at scale, take a
minute to look at Dataplex.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/dataplex.
[MUSIC PLAYING]